ouais c'est youri djorkaeff
bonsoir y aurait 13 enfants mesure qu'à
être là ça va augros s'arrange accuse
années comme écrivain c'est bien un
aïoli vous avez remporté donc la coupe
du monde en 98 le championnat d'europe
en 2000 avec les bleus est à 38 ans vous
êtes capitaine et milieu offensive des
red bull new york voilà vous vivez au
sud de manhattan
au deuxième étage d'un immeuble c'est
con à manhattan est au deuxième c'est un
peu con j'ai le vertige c'est pour ça
que j'habite au deuxième voilà vous
vivez au sud de manhattan le deuxième
étage d'un immeuble qui domine l'uni
part privée de la ville de gramercy park
même pas mal hein
et dans cet immeuble loge également du
lias roberts jouer tous les deux ils ont
les toilettes sur le palier rencontré
julien robert dans l'ascenseur et il a
dit elle est sublime nous comment vous
savez tout ça je sais tout non mais là
j'ai mis pratiquement à personne où ce
qui est là enfin les romans subit alors
en ce moment est au théâtre vous savez
le pin giulia donc très mauvaises
critiques en mai mais très grosse
recette an mal an à voilà c'est la
critique a été très dure avec très très
dur est fait démolir mais vous l'avez vu
la pièce n'ont pas encore pu y aller
jusqu'au mois de juin jusqu'au moindre
ouais il ya les suivait l'a croisé
l'ascenseur va vous dire
did you see me yann stay on allait bien
comme un censeur pour le dire ouais non
mais en fin de compte je vis dans
l'ascenseur oui mais voilà croiser tous
les jours alors le red bull vous dites
ce club cette ville était mon rêve
ouais ouais bah je sais pas je crois que
new york c'est où ça te plait ou
tout s'est elle pas où ça ne te plaît
pas et tu es vraiment un test
moi j'aime vraiment donc donc je reste
belle fin de carrière en tous les cas
pas mal oui par rapport à d'autres alors
vous êtes 38 ans j'ai eu la vie qu'une
personne du double de mon âge ne
connaîtra probablement jamais et cette
vie vous la raconter youri dans un livre
publié chez grasset qui s'appelle snake
le serpent
si votre surnom pourquoi il n'y en a pas
ce qui fait des frappes enroulées c'est
à dire que quand le ballon vers la
droite d'un seul coup sûr vers la gauche
c'est djorkaeff c'est ça ouais ça fait
quand vous faites
j'aimerais un effet au ballon qui fait
que la trajectoire elle est est comme ça
voilà snake
wesley est bien luis fernandez qui parle
pas très bien le rendez vous la pelle
seznec est une affaire la tienne alors
thierry henry lui il a un nom de
serpents aussi on l'appelle l'anaconda
mais c'est pas pour les mêmes raisons
que vous savez il est ingéré je n'ai
appris la plana combat il paraît que
c'est la seaco non c'est quoi ton binôme
à peyriac aldrin qui veut savoir
pourquoi parce qu'il a une grosse [ __ ]
katrina alors voilà alors votre prénom
c'est youri c'est pas du tout à cause de
youri gagarine
non mais à cause du docteur jivago
interprété par omar m'a alors c'est
marrant le mélange de youri ses origines
sont très étonnant de votre père jan est
d'origine kalmouke et votre mère marie
est d'origine arménienne succès la
kalmoukie j'ai une baraque là bas j mais
jamais
la kalmoukie une population de langue
mongole et ils sont bouddhistes et vous
avez hérité un petit peu vous de cette
philosophie
j'ai hérité des oueds de la philosophie
et la mentalité parce que on est des
descendants de gengis khan
voilà on est aussi des des vrais nomades
et c'est pour ça que j'ai beaucoup j'ai
beaucoup et j'en ai dans ma vie et je me
plais dans le voyage oui absolument à
votre grand père c'est un russe blanc
qui était pour le d'arrêt au moment de
la révolution évidemment en octobre 17
battus par les bolcheviks il a il a fui
en europe pour éviter d'être déporté en
sibérie
alors ça c'est la famille de votre terre
et la famille de votre mère décédée d
arméniens qui ont enterré en france pour
échapper au génocide perpétré par les
turcs
votre grand père veut rejoindre les usa
déjà et puis s'arrête à marseille et
voilà il est resté là et tout le monde
en titre aimant tout le monde s'est
retrouvé dans une petite ville à côté de
lyon une ville de 25000 habitants qui
s'appelle de sin tout voilà et votre
père jean alors jean djorkaeff déjà
grand joueur de foot
deux victoires en coupe de france 48
sélections dans l'équipe nationale et la
moitié en tant que capitaine c'est pas
être facile quand vous étiez petit
d'avoir un père pareil d'exister à côté
de lui quoi way effet c'est jamais
facile pour les fils de
mais j'ai toujours eu des bons rapports
avec mon père donc ça s'est assez bien
passé
il m'a jamais poussé déjà joué au
football ouais j'ai tapé mon premier
ballon en tiennent compte
en suivant l'exemple de mon frère et
quand j'ai commencé à avoir un bon
niveau il a été là pour me conseiller
mais il m'a jamais remplacer donc j'ai
pas fait de rejet du père j'ai pas voulu
tuer mon père et ça s'est bien passé ça
soit ça se passe bien alors à 66 ans
votre père entraîne luge et à l'union
générale arménienne et vous êtes à ses
militants de l'arménie non ben oui on
est pas on n'est pas nombreux
quand même d'origine arménienne on est
de moins en moins puis puis s'est passé
j'ai quand même passé un génocide que la
turquie ne veut toujours pas reconnaître
donc il faut il faut il faut élever sa
voix à lyon a été inauguré un mémorial à
la mémoire du génocide arménien qui
était profané instantanément ce qui veut
dire que c'est quand même des choses qui
sont toujours très vivante quoi mais je
trouve qu'il ya bien ce qui est ce qui a
vraiment était important c'était la
réaction du gouvernement français
la réaction des dd non arméniens j'ai ce
con con les premiers crier chez on two
way alors un peu comme béatrice dalle
dont une voyante avait annoncé le
fabuleux destin vous vous raconter quand
cm2 vous et fine rédaction le thème la
rédaction c'était quand je serai grand
et vous avez écrit quand je serai grand
je serai footballeur
ouais et je le perds en dix ans m
ouais c'est vous non ouais je serai
ouais c'est fou parce que la rédaction
commence par je serai footballeur je
serai professionnel je gagnerai la coupe
du monde et je jouerai jeunes il s'agit
des roberts
j'ai juré à new york cosmos un cosmos de
new york et j'avais 10 ans et c'est aux
rédactions gelé eu en main après la
coupe du monde et a eu combien comme
note
très bien et ma maîtresse a donné ce
taux rédaction après la finale à coude
où on la voit la grande question du me
pose c'est pourquoi elle a gardé aussi
longtemps
mais malgré ce garde du courrier souvent
et puis toi oui c'est vrai l'envoyer à
vos parents après le 12 juillet 98
voilà un extraordinaire cette histoire
alors vous racontez votre carrière vous
raconter les hauts les bas tous vos
déplacements de club en club et il s'est
passé pas évident parce que maintenant
c'est à new york mais il aurait fallu
quand même des coupures et ballon pour
en arriver là
et alors vous raconter ce match terrible
laurent tu sais qui m'a profondément
marqué le 17 novembre 93 le match contre
la bulgarie 1-1 et la 69e minute ginola
remplace papin reste 23 secondes
ginola centre plutôt que de conserver le
ballon et là les bulgares
c'était mérité cnra l'eau je sais pas
vous mais hélas le bulgare prend le
ballon remonte tout le terrain le fameux
kostadinov emile constant
c'était bien joué mais humainement
j'étais pas très correct techniquement
d'accord mais c'était terrible que les
gens mettaient déjà leurs manteaux et
tout le monde s'en aller quoi on faisait
même plus gaffe à ce qui se passait sur
le terrain
et puis cinq minutes après il y avait le
maquillage bleu blanc rouge comme ça qui
dégoulinait avec les larmes et tous
était d'une beauté totale sur tous les
matins c'est dramatique dramatique
affaire m'a menti
on avait deux matches à la maison pour
ramener juste 1.1 pour l'un pour aller à
la coupe du monde aux états unis et on
joue contre israël et la bulgarie on
perd les deux mâts de la voilà alors
ginola crucifié évidemment oulié parle
de crime contre l'équipe c du jeu long
quand même il ya en virgine aulas mais
quand il vient ici qu'on parle de nous
lier ses allées séminaire vient
bah oui parce que enfin quand on fait un
sport collectif
ouais enfin un sport collectif et je
crois aussi bien dans la victoire que
dans la défaite
sara lee l'air c'est comme dans une
partouze situera tout y passe
vous racontez aussi le 16 février 94
quelques mois plus tard donc aimé
jacquet a remplacé ou liés il a annoncé
à cantona qui fait pas partie de
l'équipe de france et il vous convoque
zidane et vous êtes-vous dit vous êtes
mes deux soleils et maintenant des amis
s'est passé c'est que les les grosses
stars à l'époque était aussi bien canton
akouè que ginola que papin et et zizou
et moi nous n'avions pas d'expérience
internationale et jacquet lui en 94 les
pensées des gens déjà la coupe du monde
98 4 en avant et il voulait faire une
génération pour pour gagner se coupe du
monde et il voulait s'appuyer sur des
chemins sont des jeunes montant qui voit
là il alors nous a convoqués dans dans
son bureau et s'est retrouvé là et ainsi
a dit bon voilà je ne prends pas eric je
prends pas david mais je compte sur vous
pour pour éclairer le jeu de l'équipe de
france alors là vous battez l'italie ce
n'est pas arrivé depuis 82 ans et vous
marquez votre premier but nous franchir
et je monte mon image titulaire mon
premier but italien rocco toujours
marqué les esprits c'était bien et puis
vous raconter évidemment le 12 juillet
1998 la france championne du monde et
finalement alors là c'est un des
passages les plus étonnants de votre
bouquin c'est que après le 12 juillet
vous êtes complètement flippé quoi vous
m'exprimer devenu un calvaire j'étais
cloître et j'étais ému et irascible avec
ma femme et mes enfants fin et un espèce
de baby blues quoi tout à faire
c'est ça tu gagnes la coupe du monde ce
qui est le summum dans nombre dans notre
sport et tu te dis après qu'est ce qu'il
ya et j'ai eu besoin de temps pour pour
pour rechercher un nouveau défi
nouvelles nouvelles quêtes pour pouvoir
continuer j'étais trop jeune pour
arrêter il y avait 30 ans alain delà de
la finale et
il fallait que je continue mais ça a été
dur j'ai eu un mois difficile très très
bas après ce qui a eu malheureusement
c'est le mondial-2002 2002 on est passé
à travers
ouais là vous accusez carrément roger
lemerre sisina là si vous dites qu'il
avait pas de plan qui vous a pas dit
jean fallait faire que j'accuse
j'accuse j'accuse les types parce qu'on
n'a pas été bon j'ai vécu je sais que ce
n'est pas parce qu'il n'a pas été bon
non plus je crois je crois qu'on n'a pas
été on n'a pas été à la hauteur
c'est une accumulation de détails qui
font la différence à ce niveau là et et
on était aussi ont le titre tellement de
bien préparer pour contrer tous ces
détails en 98 qu'on a été qu'on était
vraiment surpris en 2002 que ça se passe
pas bien
voilà après vous raconter le cauchemar
allemand et le rêve américain
je préfère raconter le rêve américain
compte bien faire on parlait du rêve
américain puisque en allemagne je
connais j'ai eu du mal en allemagne
c'est une chose que j'aie j'avais envie
de raconter mais qui est difficile en
parler mais celle que vous avez
tellement de mal en allemagne que là on
vous a proposé d'aller faire des
commentaires pour le mondial cet été et
maintenant je refais ou plus les pieds
en allemagne quand même je suis invité
pour voir s'il y a il ya un grand
dilemme parce que je suis invité pour
pour le premier match de la coupe du
monde
l'ouverture la coupe du monde tous les
anciens de l'équipe de france on va se
retrouver et ils m'ont appelé mon livre
il faut donner une réponse et j'hésite
parce que j'ai une réaction
ouais qu'est ce qui s'est passé en
allemagne et il ya mon entraîneur qui a
voulu faire une petit m'a fait du mal
moralement qui essaie de faire du mal et
de me détruire en tant que joueur donc
mais c'est quelqu'un qui va me qui m'a
mis à l'écart pendant par un trois mois
je me suis entraîné tout seul tous les
jours tout seul mais qu'est ce qu'il
avait dit et j'ai lut vous c'est ça
ouais ouais ouais c'est la psychologie
quand même est complètement ça veut dire
le matin j'arrivais personnes me
calculait il y avait un préparateur
physique était uniquement pour moi donc
je parte en forêt pendant une heure a
mis à courir sans boussole sans boussole
et et voilà c'était ça mes entraînements
si vous interdisez de jouer en équipe de
france aussi
elle interdisait de jouer en club donc
en ile de france et est surtout ils
voulaient pas me transférer
donc j'avais j'avais un gros salaire
dans cette équipe là mais pour eux il
était hors de question de me transférer
voulait que que je finis chichi ou que
je casse complètement non contre un
poème d'argent avec le fisc aussi le
jour où où je suis parti d'allemagne
à la fin j'ai réussi à négocier mon
départ donc je suis parti j'ai mis la
pression au club et je leur ai dit voilà
où je fais des déclarations
à toute la presse et je fais un bordel
pas possible dans le club où vous me
laisser partir
je convoque toute la presse et j'ai un
quart d'heure avant avant la conférence
de presse je prends mon président je dis
on fait la conférence de presse ensemble
et on se serre la main et vous vous
dites il part ou alors j'ai fait tout
tout seul et je fais exploser le club je
suis parti il m'a donné mon bon de
sortie ouais lendemain matin j'avais la
police à 6 heures du matin chez moi
j'avais un mandat d'arrêt et j'avais et
le fils que m'a bloqué mais compte
pendant quatre mois
1 et ils ont fait les enquêtes sont en
quête bon j'ai rien j'ai bien joué j'ai
pas de problème et c'est pour ça que
j'ai une certaine réticence à retourner
en allemagne
oui vous serez pas là je suis une
histoire de fous j'ai jamais eu
l'impression d'être un fugitif alors que
j'avais il y avait juste demandé à jouer
vous êtes optimiste sur les chances des
bleues en allemagne la ouais ouais ouais
nan sérieusement
non mais sérieusement j'ai l'impression
que tout le monde pose cette question
j'ai ensuite on était super content en
2002 on s'est pris un gala donc
maintenant je crois qu'on a on a une des
meilleures équipes
on n'a pas à part le brésil qui était au
dessus du lot je trouve qu'on a on
allait super bien voilà on a une belle
équipe et on va être compétitif ce que
ce que j'aime dans l'équipe de france
c'est que quand la des parcours
difficiles à la qualification et
généralement ça un bon mondial anelka va
être qualifié j'espère pour lui et
franck ribéry sincèrement je le connais
pas oui c'est un bon joueur et il paraît
et pareil j'ai jamais vu jouer donc il
par un très bon joueur bon qu'est ce que
j'allais faire après alors quand il est
revenu aux états unis dirigé lors l on
voit pas le président le président du
club de lyon à
c'est fait bien les choses c'est très
bien qu'on voit la fim est champion
c'est historique dans champion de france
mais bon il n'est pas éternel hélas ils
l'aiment bien son club
ouais ouais la menace à près de
raccrocher aux pneus je crois pas eu
elle son club alors vous raconter dans
votre bouquin comment vous rencontré
votre votre femme sophie gimenez dans
lequel s'était parents et espagnol donc
c'est un mélange entre des calmes ou des
arméniens des espagnols c'est également
avec les polonais
ouais si c'est oui et alors elle est
tellement amoureuse de vous qu'elle part
en angleterre et elle revient c'est très
beau quand même la gauche ne fait pas
que le bouquin non mais alors ils
passent de google n'y a pas que le
bouquin oui ma femme faisait des études
de traductrice est de faire elle devait
de partir d'angleterre pour parfaire son
anglais est au bout de deux semaines
elle est revenue pour continuer aventure
avec moi et voilà bon vivre et ça dure
depuis c'est vrai ça va bien super elle
vous a quand même bien s'agit quoi
ouais voyez une époque c'est normal on
est ensemble